This video is brought to you by Adam and Eve.
Go to Adam and eve.com and use the promo code C at checkout to get 50% off one
item and free shipping in the U S and Canada.
Let's start the show.
So different and he sold him. But the freedom,
if you wanted to have a legend of a comedian,
you talk about a guy who created the greatest sketch show of all time.
Then he goes away and the show went really well. Like absurdly. Well, like so,
well you got to go to Africa.
Well, I quit Chappelle show in spectacular, fast. Hey,
everybody got an in the night. I quit.
It goes away like a mountain.
Excuse me to us. This is for 10 years, I was gone.
I watched the world go on without me. I'm born the laws of it.
And then came back and immediately went right to the top.
No one's ever done it better than Dave.
He sat in the time where the fire is the hottest I'm going to do what
nobody else will. Dave, you're the goat.
Dave Chappelle.
Anyway,
this is weird and less than ideal.
Dave Chappelle special eight 46 reminded us all. What we already knew,
Chappelle is more than just a comedian. He's a legend and an iconic figure.
Just one who also tells jokes.
Personally, kit Candace Owens in her stinky.
This performance shows Dave's incredible flexibility as an artist.
Not only was it filmed in the middle of a pandemic that has prevented standup
comedy for months, but in his own words.
Not funny at all.
The special only has a little bit of humor in it.
And the rest contains a powerful and personal reflection on the black lives
matter protests.
The performance reminds you of just how legendary Dave Chappelle is that he can
use his artistry in the most unexpected ways to do stand up in the most
unexpected situations. And he's always been this way.
He did the same thing after quitting Chappelle show,
he was doing stand-up in a park in Seattle.
He'd show up with a box and just do it,
plug a microphone into it and just start doing Stanhope throughout his life.
Chappelle has made more out of his career than just telling jokes and in doing
so, he's become more than a comedian. He's a legend,
the risk taking the pressure, the comeback, the controversy,
it all points to an Epic narrative that transcends his own life.
It's a story of a man perfecting his artistry,
reaffirming his personal agency and learning to perform his art on his own
terms. And it's a story that's influenced by and adds to the narratives of other
African-American artists.
Pretty much every article or video about Dave Chappelle focuses on the jokes he
tells and to whether they're funny or not funny.
And that makes sense since joke telling is the comedian's job.
But I think that sells Dave Chappelle shorts.
If he's really a legend and a thought leader, shouldn't we go deeper than that.
What if you study Dave's life and body of work as if he were a legendary artists
like Charlie Parker or Kendrick Lamar,
or even an intellectual like Frederick Douglas,
because I think Dave Chappelle deserves to be treated in that way.
There's an incredible amount of meaning and depth packed into his career,
along with the jokes.
[Inaudible].
So let's see what Dave Chappelle's body of work looks like when you approach it.
As more than just the work of a joke teller.
An iconic figure. I'm a pop culture figures.
That's much different. I don't know.
Sometimes they take time and figure it began me to clap.
[inaudible].
In 2002, Dave Chappelle co-created Chappelle show with Neil Brennan,
which would go on to become one of the most successful sketch comedy shows of
all time. But in the middle of filming the third season,
he abandoned his $50 million contract and went to South Africa for a few weeks.
I already made a video about why Dave Chappelle left his show on comedy central.
I talked about an analogy he made in his special,
the bird revelation in the analogy. Chappelle is a prostitute.
His sex work is his work on Chappelle show.
And his pimps are the Hollywood executives who manipulated him into overworking
under abusive conditions, pale show, 20 hours a day.
Sleep for like half an hour. Raise my kids for 10, 20 minutes.
And it wasn't fun at all. It was hard.
We'd have to stay awake for 48 hours at a time just to keep up with the
schedule. We were bombed out and depleted. We were lumped in.
According to the bird revelation Chapelle left the show because of that
unbearable schedule and to the psychological abuse executive used to try to keep
him going.
Why the you think most of us work from nine to five? It's nine to six,
my killer.
But Chappelle has also mentioned other reasons for quitting. Hmm.
Wondered about its impact on the audience that he meant it for.
He felt disturbed at how some white audience members misread his racial humor.
So.
There was white laugh in such a way.
I know different people laughing with me and people laughing at me and was the
first time I'd ever gotten a laugh that I was uncomfortable with.
Why people would come well to me like, man, that just gets you did about them.
That was her luck. Take it easy.
You start to realize these sketches in the wrong hands are dangerous.
Really? There wasn't one singular reason for him to leave.
I wasn't walking away from money. I was walking away from the perfect storm of.
And unsurprisingly,
the media didn't understand the nuance of his decision with mainstream outlets,
circulating crazy unfounded claims about his disappearance.
Saying, you know, yes, no crack. And it was all in your window.
And then magazine is credible as Newsweek. I was surprised.
The media didn't see that his decision wasn't a meltdown,
but rather a calculated personal decision that defined his identity going
forward.
I'm like, man, I didn't. I walked down. I walked back down, Wayne.
Aaron himself to John Wayne shows that Chappelle sees his decision as more
significant than just leaving a job. He didn't like,
like John Wayne disappearing into the wilderness in the searchers Chappelle
exercise, complete control despite his uncertain destiny.
And your price in the beginning,
if it ever gets more expensive than the pricing name, get out of it.
The effort.
There's a long tradition of African-American icons,
visiting Africa and undergoing a transformation.
Everybody should go home to Africa.
That's the all colors of people doing everything. And if I said, do you see any?
I said, no. As a, you know why? Because there aren't any,
and it hit me like a shot, man.
I started crying and on this pilgrimage.
What I have seen and experienced has forced me to rearrange much of my thought
patterns previously held and to toss aside some of my previous conclusions.
Yeah, you hear a lot of black people say this, like when you go to Africa,
especially your first time you have this overwhelming feeling like you're home,
which is true. I, I, I had a feeling like, man, this feels like home.
And liking the narratives of other prominent black figures.
Chappelle presents his journey to Africa as a profound teachable moment in his
life that protested against the hostilities of show business and racial
injustice.
I feel like I'm going to be some kind of parable by either what you're
supposed to do or what you're not supposed to. I'm going to beat something.
I'm either going to be a legend or just that tragic story,
but I'm going full throttle. I'm going on away.
Choice to go to South Africa.
And the way he talks about that choice clearly shows he sees his decision as
more meaningful than just a career move. Even now,
after leaving show business for 10 years, he presents his life as a parable,
a narrative to learn from and in doing so he elevates his story into myth.
Look at Boone's always have a secret supply of water.
And they're not going to tell anybody where it is.
I watched one of these nature shows one time and they were talking about how a
Bush man finds water when it's scares.
And they do what's called assault.
First.
He laborious it drills a hole in a giant antique when he is shored up a boot and
is watching him because he knows, but boons are incurably. Inquisitive.
Put a lump of salt in a hole and they wait for the bat. Boom.
The baboons comes, sticking his hand in the hole, grabs the salt.
Salt makes the have bigger and he's trapped. He can't get his hand out.
That'd be smart. All he does is let go with assault.
BABEN doesn't want to let go of stuff.
Now he lets go. When it's too late.
Which man is comes, takes the bathroom and gives him all the salt he wants.
You know, when you're a guy that generates money,
people have a vested interest in control.
In fact, he has such a bully salt that he completely forgets.
He's under arrest and that in a little while, he's going to be a mighty thirsty,
but baboon.
You know what kills more black people than anything. One police and terrorism,
salt Lake, a regular table. Salt with that bone gets thirsty.
The Bush man, that's somebody.
He decides the brainwashing has worked.
So he sets him free knowing that in his condition,
he won't care who follows him to the seat. But reservoir.
That wasn't paying attention.
I felt really guilty about being asleep at the wheel.
The first piece of bamboo runs to his water, which may have followed him.
And they both turned to them. And then that analogy, I felt like the boom,
but I was smart enough to let go of it.
If you had to say to drop the seed, he could feel his hand.
I want to give the money to someone that's not exploiting.
The machine is good for us and we good for the machine. Then it should be,
should be fair, man. Should it be fair?
You know what? Uh, it's been 10 years.
Since the last time I played Los Angeles.
2017 Chappelle released his first two posts,
Chappelle show concert films on Netflix,
deep in the heart of Texas and the age of spin while they don't linger much on
his past controversies with Chappelle show,
they do acknowledge they're still on his mind.
It was a difficult 10 years. I'm not going to take you through all the agony.
Yeah.
The specials don't speak much to the Dave Chappelle narrative.
That may be because he shot the specialist without any streaming deal.
And Netflix bought them later. I literally just took them out of the class.
Like they're both well-made and funny specials.
And they gave the world a re-introduction to Chappelle and primarily serve to
show he's still got it. And by omitting the controversy of him,
quitting Chappelle show and leaving show business for 10 years,
the specials also create dramatic tension.
Everybody still wants to know how all that affected him.
He resolves that tension in his next two specials,
equanimity and the bird revelation.
These specials clearly seek to address the demons from his Chappelle show days.
One clue is their titles. The first is called equanimity,
which means an evenness of mind, especially under stress.
His very first joke makes it clear that his comedy is now in his hands.
And after this, it's time to make America wait again.
The entire opening shows a comedian who understands his talent and knows how to
resist to the force of others.
Black and show business and do too well. It's scary.
Like you gotta get the out of the casino while the getting's good while you're
still winning.
If equanimity reflects a comedian in control,
then the following special shows how he got there.
This next special feels much more intimate. And it's my personal favorite.
It's called the bird revelation. And that title actually has multiple meanings.
The first interpretation relates to the prostitution analogy at the end of the
special, the word bird is slang for a girl.
And Dave knows that he even uses the word bird in this way during a sketch on
Chappelle show.
One of those that you just bring it home. Well,
you bring it home and wear out.
The bird revelation is Dave having the revelation that while at Chappelle show,
he was the bird getting worn out. This capital's manifested.
And that's why I went to South Africa.
Another interpretation of the title has to do with the quote.
At the beginning of the special I came alive,
I could fly this quote was supposedly said by Charlie Parker,
after he realized a completely new way to play music, Charlie Parker,
his nickname was bird. Hence the bird revelation.
This second meeting also relates to Chappelle's career like Charlie Parker,
Chappelle realized he could do his art form in a completely new way.
After years of leaving comedy, he has come back completely differently.
Now he can make comedy without the executives who pushed him too far in short
he's free.
It was scary. Now I feel like it's liberate. Like I feel free.
Like I can just say what I want to do. I, when they already call me crazy.
The narrative of the life of Dave Chappelle is defined by one word, freedom.
Chapelle is no longer bound by the will of executives and can now work on his
own terms.
And there's really no other comedian with the level of freedom that Dave
Chappelle has. You know,
I've got the corporate relationships in the CEO hat in the
companies. So, you know, I can't do certain things.
And then Kevin said, it. I quit.
And then he went on every talk show in America and apologize for six weeks.
Envious and jealous of Dave's ability to go and be free as
a comic in the times where we desperately need to be.
I'm going to go to Africa. I'm going to find a way to,
I'm going to find a way to be myself. I'm an artist, man. You know, I don't,
I don't need a snake.
That's why we have a sneaker deal. Cause if you say something people don't like,
they'll take your shoes.
Chappelle truly does whatever he wants.
Sometimes it feels like he breaks the rules just to remind us that he can.
And also tell you that I skipped rehearsal during the civil rights movement.
Uh, I can't,
I can't read what's on the teleprompter and I want everyone in America right now
to look at me, look at me, smoking in doors.
I didn't ask anybody. I just did it. What are they gonna do?
Kick me out before I get the prize. Now, this is called leverage.
Everyone embraces Chappelle's ability to resist the poles of show business,
especially in an era where show business has received a huge amount of
completely warranted criticism.
But those aren't the only people Chappelle doesn't want controlling him.
Cure. What I find out could be today, tomorrow 15, 20 years from now,
if I find out you're through finished,
that's you, that's what the audience sounds like to me.
The title of his latest special sticks and stones has a pretty clear meaning.
Chappelle is reminding us that criticisms of him aren't going to hurt him or his
comedy. And in classic Dave Chappelle fashion,
he references other black provocateurs to explain what he's doing. First.
The opening quote, tell me something to. Can't tell me nothing. I read the
[inaudible] and even more explicitly.
He quilts Prince lyrics that essentially summarize his entire argument. Yeah.
And this was the bar,
the whole song Prince say trying to run from my
destruction. You know what I did? And even chaos.
As Marine Callahan noted,
he is telling us that he is willing to not just destroy, but be destroyed.
If you consider Chappelle's career up to this point,
his decision to continue telling destructive jokes about things he already got
backlash for should come as no surprise Chapelle. Isn't just telling jokes.
He's making a broader point.
Just like when he actively resist the rules of show business.
He also resists to bowing down to criticism to remind us that his comedy will
always be his and his alone,
whether it's TV executives or his audience Chappelle will fight back against any
attempt to restrict what he says.
Some people prefer Chappelle's older comedy over his recent work.
And I totally get that his first two specials killing them softly.
And for what it's worth are easily, two of the best comedy shows of all time.
But I do enjoy how his more recent work incorporates the narrative of his life
into his performances.
And sometimes he also adds his experience to the work of other performers.
A perfect example is Chappelle's interruption of Kendrick Lamar's performance
during the Grammys in 2018.
I'm Dave Chappelle.
And I just wanted to remind the audience that the only thing more frightening
than watching a black man be honest in America is being an honest black man in
America. Sorry for the interruption. Please continue.
This theatrical interruption is full of meaning.
Speaking specifically to the nature of black artistry in the United States.
The fact that Chappelle introduces himself feels almost funny since everybody
clearly knows who he is,
but that introduction emphasizes that these are not words coming from just
anybody they're coming from Dave Chapelle, another honest black man in America,
his presence becomes an authoritative comment on the obstacles and risks of a
black man performing his art without holding back.
It looks like you're singing the dancing. It was brothers taking a note.
And in the same way that Kendrick Lamar is not just singing and dancing.
Dave Chappelle is not just telling jokes in eight 46,
Dave Chappelle heavily criticizes the conservative commentator, Candace Owens.
I can't think of a worse way to make money.
And Owens responded that people need to be able to laugh at themselves.
So she's okay with Chappelle talking about her that way in the end,
she probably would've made the criticism worse. If she fought back,
there's really no good way to respond to a comedian acting freely.
And truthfully, because if you accept that comedians can say anything,
then you have to accept that criticism when it's directed at you,
even if it's brutal, but if you disagree with what a comedian says,
then you can be criticized for taking them too seriously.
And nobody plays both of these sides more than Dave Chappelle.
Sometimes he's just telling jokes. That don't mean anything.
And sometimes he's telling hard truths. That mean a lot.
And he's also doing everything in between his latest,
special 46 and his performance at the Grammy's confirm that he's not just a
comedian, but also not just a thought leader.
He's both and full of contradictions.
Like do people care what he has to say or not?
I know nobody gives a what I think anyway,
the reason people want to hear from people like me is because.
Trust me, is he telling it like it is? Or is he just messing around?
I was right once. Remember that I didn't come here to be right. Give me the.
Is he a thought leader or is he just telling jokes?
I pride myself on saying real people don't even
notice I'm saying. Uh, and, and then sometimes I just tell jokes.
Yeah.
There's even something kind of strange about this video taking Dave Chappelle
very seriously, despite the fact that some of his comedy is just plain silly.
There's just not enough.
Stove, top stuff for everybody.
So I kicked her in the.
Yeah. That is the beauty of Dave Chappelle.
He lives in this limbo between jokes and sincerity and he can effortlessly move
between them if he's really a legend than his work deserves to be treated like
art. But if he's also a hilarious comedian,
then his work doesn't need to be treated like art at all.
You can just laugh at it.
His comedy is simultaneously a joke and more than just a joke serious and
non-serious offensive and not offensive.
My favorite book of all time, narrative of the life of Frederick.
Dave Chappelle has an intimate connection with the great abolitionist Frederick
Douglas.
To my knowledge,
it's the first black person that was officially invited to the white house was
Frederick Douglas.
I talked about how few black people were invited to the Winehouse,
how Frederick Douglas was the first and that it didn't happen again until
Roosevelt, but that was wrong. It happened one other time before that,
that delegation was led by that AME Bishop
William David Chappelle,
where I get my name was my great-grandfather,
who was a slave when he was born.
And not only does Chappelle's lineage have similarities with Douglas,
but they also both create narratives out of their life stories.
The exact phrasing of the title of Douglas as memoir is crucial.
It's not titled the life of Frederick Douglas,
but rather the narrative of the life of Frederick Douglas.
His first memoir has a lot of thematic similarities with other slave narratives.
The story functions, not just as a recounting of Frederick Douglass's life,
but also a story that fits into the greater narrative of overcoming slavery in
the American South.
According to historian James only these narratives have three key elements,
literacy identity,
and freedom slaves learned to read and write in difficult situations,
invent a new social identity for themselves and live their lives as Freeman and
abolitionists.
Only his most interesting claim is that these narrative elements actually occur
past slavery and into African-American literature in the Jim Crow era with
stories like black boy and the autobiography of Malcolm X,
addressing similar ideas of learning to educate oneself,
reinventing one's own identity and advocating for freedom from oppression.
Dave Chappelle embraces his relationship with Frederick Douglas and in many
ways,
Chappelle story has parallels with that traditional Afro American narrative.
His literature is his artistry as a comic.
His identity is the independence he declared by going to Africa.
And his freedom is advocating to say what he wants on stage,
where he knows who he is, right. And in that compromise.
And no one can tell him.
Any different. I understand what I am. I really do more than anybody.
When is we going to be free? That is a good question, man. Man.
How about now?
Dave Chappelle tells his story by recontextualizing it in the stories of other
African-American figures, whether it's through a pimp in the forties,
Frederick Douglas visiting the white house or Kendrick Lamar,
he finds a commonality in these stories and that commonality elevates his story
and his career to that of a legend,
the vast majority of articles or videos about Dave Chappelle analyze his jokes.
But I think that sells his career short. Obviously his comedy is amazing,
but within his comedy specials, he also contextualizes his artistry.
He celebrates other black intellectuals to elevate the meaning of his career
choices and by doing so he becomes an intellectual in his own, right?
They've Chappelle is an amazing comedian because he has some amazing jokes,
but it's what he says between those jokes that makes him legendary.
This is not fun.
I got some jokes too. I could do, but I just really just.
I released this video on October 27th,
which is officially Dave Chappelle day in the city of DC where I live.
So how does he want us to celebrate.
And the future on Dave Chappelle day, I ask everyone who wishes to celebrate it,
to make one incredible memory for themselves and or somebody else,
or maybe do it a different way from now on, on October 27th,
everybody and out of me at Duke Ellington school.
Dave Chappelle's comedy highlights, countless black artists,
and he also frequently highlights important historical events in the black
community, like the crack epidemic,
the civil rights movement and the HIV pandemic. In fact,
one of Chappelle's first on-screen appearances was to rap about AIDS awareness,
but it's men and women and the young ladies,
if you want to be like young Dave Chappelle and support combating HIV,
then a company I recommend for you to check out is Adam and Eve,
Adam and Eve is an adult store that donates 20% of their profits to help fight
the spread of HIV around the world. Go to Adam and eve.com and use the code.
See at checkout to get 50% off one item and free shipping in the U S and Canada.
They have discreet shipping and 90 day, no hassle returns,
a big thanks to Adam and Eve for sponsoring this video and to big,
thanks to our supporters on Patrion who got early access to this video and have
access to our new podcast. Now you hear it in each episode,
my co-creator Andrew and I break down our video,
discuss related topics and talk about the things that couldn't fit into a
YouTube video. You can check out the first episode for free in the link below.
And if you like it,
head to our Patrion to get access to all the subsequent episodes,
including this week's new episode about Dave Chappelle. Thanks for watching.